- So Steve, tell me about
this beautiful '66 Cadillac.
- My parents
were original owners.
- Your parents owned this car?
- They did.
They brought this car home
when I was five years old.
- Oh, my gosh!
- And, um, I've been
around this car
for 50 years.
- What's up, Kev?
- It was my, uh, car
in high school and college.
- Is that right?
- Sorry to interrupt.
- Quite all right.
- No, that's okay.
Ryan, Steve, Steve, Ryan.
This is his beautiful
'66 Cadillac.
- Yeah!
'66 Cadillac convertible!
- So my wife and I went
to our high school prom,
you know, in this car.
- You're kidding?
- I started to have it
put back together
several years ago,
and I would love nothing more
than for you guys
to finish it up.
- Well, we appreciate you
bringing it to us,
'cause we do have
a knack for these.
- Yeah.
- You know, the one thing
I will tell you is that
when Danny sees this...
- Mm-hmm.
- You know he's gonna want it.
- Okay.
[both laughing]
So the car has a tremendous
amount of history,
you know, for me,
and such an important project.
- This is great, and it looks
like all the pieces
and parts are here, too.
- Should be.
- Whatcha think, sir?
- At a quick glance, it's...
not perfectly straight,
- Mm-hmm.
- But my biggest pet peeve
is the paint is a little
blotchy.
I would love to repaint this
thing and make it perfect...
- Mm-hmm.
- But that definitely
changes the budget a lot.
- Yeah.
- It really is a beautiful car.
- Thank you very much.
- I'm jealous.
[laughter]
- Danny will be, too.
- Thanks, Ry.
- Thank you.
- Now, do you know,
did they redo the, uh,
the drive train?
- They did.
Engine's been rebuilt,
transmission's been rebuilt.
- Wow! Okay...
- Um...
It did start out
as a frame off restoration.
- Oh!
- So a lot of that
has already been completed.
Just desperately need your help
in putting it back together.
- Back together.
And finishing it off.
- Yeah.
- All right.
Well, that's great.
Let's go to the office,
and, uh, let's work up
some numbers.
- Okay.
- All right. Beautiful car.
Congratulations.
- Thank you very much.